[Music]
bob joins us in new brunswick new jersey
bob welcome to the ramsay show
hey thanks for having me guys i
appreciate it absolutely thank you
um i
turned 62 years old this year
and that means that i could potentially
well i will have access to my
self-employment pension so you talk
about education i am an educator i teach
boating education as in uh drive a boat
on the water very cool and um how long
have you done that for bob sir
i've been doing it for a
good part of 12 13 years now very cool
man
prior to that i was uh self-employed as
a mobile disc jockey weddings bank with
parties all that good stuff and
then prior to that worked out a
pharmaceutical company realized that i
didn't really want to work in corporate
america but anyway well the first time i
took my boat out i recognized in short
order i probably should have had some
classes on how to even do what i'm doing
he needed you bob where were you bob i'm
glad there are people like you out in
the world keeping the water safe from
people like me so what's up man i i
do i do my best at it i really do and
and and on top of that i really really
enjoy what i do so i'm really blessed
and uh
so so the challenges that i have noticed
i didn't say problems the challenges
that i have are all first world
challenges
um i do have debt and i have money to
pay it off
i'm just looking for some common sense
uh
advice here on
how to go about doing that now again
emergency fund you know taking care of
uh you know plenty of money in the set
between you know between uh my wife's uh
403 b and my set where we have plenty uh
plenty that you know to cover these uh
debts however um you know i just want to
throw these things at you we have a
mortgage uh we put solar on top of our
house so and i purchased that as opposed
to leasing it
uh you have car loan and uh and my son
has a loan that uh i want to get some
advice on uh that he's uh working
towards becoming a commercial pilot so
um you know the loan rates could be a
little better and i think with my credit
rating i might be able to do well too so
talk to me on
what would be the best uh best way you
know
to pay these off so bob you said you
have a car loan
for your own personal debt you've got
the mortgage your personal mortgage and
a car loan that's it for you
uh the solar loan as well oh i thought
you said you purchased it outright
oh you took a loan out yes okay okay
well again purchase as opposed to lease
oh
okay all right so you've got the solar
panels like the solar renewable energy
credits in new jersey they're very uh
forward-thinking and uh
for each uh
s-rack i'm i'm getting 220 put right
into my bank account so okay all right
so here's what we teach is the baby
steps of course the debt snowball and
you said you already have an emergency
fund and you have the cash to pay for it
is this cash in the retirement accounts
or is it liquid innocent it is yes it is
you don't have the money in a savings
account in cash to pay for it you would
have to dip into those retirement funds
at this point
that is correct
okay
what's the car loan how much on that
uh it's 23 000. and what about the
solar solar is 43 000.
that's going to take a while to to roi
on even at 200
well because i have an electric vehicle
um that actually has taken it down to
according to my calculations if i
included that without the electric
vehicle charging
uh my my payback is 7.67
years is that what the sales person told
you
or is that with the no no when you
i did take the 30 federal tax credit
okay
all right so the car loan is gonna go
first bob so that's what we have to
tackle first i don't know what the car
is worth uh is it worth more than 23
yeah it's a it's yeah it's a uh
it's a 2020 tesla okay
so it's it's roughly worth uh i paid i
paid 50 000 for it so
i'm going to say it's probably 45 000
now okay
well
if you want to do it the ramsey way
you're going to have to line these up
from smallest to largest if i'm you i'm
right now bob truthfully i'm probably
selling the tesla until you make an spot
well uh household income is it varies
because of because of my business but
it's uh generally between 150 and 200.
okay so i i mean you can hang on to the
car there you got 20 left on it
23 23. so we got about 66 total in debt
that is non-mortgage bob from what i'm
hearing and with your income could you
not pay this off in the next eight
months yeah you should be done in less
than a year pay that off
your car pay off everything and do it
with your income that makes the most
sense that's you know i could i could
definitely do that so i would love to
see you and your wife just buckle down
for 10 months and pay off the solar and
pay off your car and then knock out this
mortgage how much you got left in the
mortgage
uh it's uh 60k oh bob what do you mean
bob
you could be done with this whole thing
in a year
done
max two years then you're what 64.
and then you're doing some assaults out
in the street with no shirt on because
you don't owe anybody any money
and then you could be like you know what
no i don't work on wednesdays just
because i don't want to how much you
have in retirement accounts
uh
well that's like i said that i we have
first world problems two and a half
million dollars oh my gosh bob i'm good
i retract this entire phone call yeah
let's go back to square one bob
in fact this is normally a free call
yeah no you're killing it dude you're
crushing it i wouldn't touch the
retirement bob you can cash flow this
whole thing and let that retirement grow
and not unplug it quite yet absolutely
yeah pay the stuff off before the year
is over and stop working down bob stop
touching debt get away from it no more
debt no more loans no more anything you
can do this man you got this you're a
baby steps millionaire we just got to
follow the plan to a t to do it the
right way this is the ramsay show